amedeo amadei schreibt ihr müsst in
italien silvester feiern was in berlin
passiert ist nur ein teil des feuerwerks
in italien
dann lass uns doch mal einen namen video
wunder denn vielleicht kommt ja
tatsächlich nicht sie haben ja vorbei
amando beschreibt noch nie gehört dass
es hier in deutschland als unglück
gelten sollte man vor nur ein frohes
neues jahr wünscht ich habe es vorher
schon auf facebook wird uns vor beides
bringt das dann auch gleich ja hallo
liebe leute wir sind zurück und
beantworten heute wieder eure fragen
nach einer dreiwöchigen weihnachtspause
ja im letzten zwei wochen ist viel
passiert weihnachten silvester wir haben
euch alles gezeigt was wir so gemacht
haben und hier sind eure fragen dazu
diese frage ist noch zu einer etwas
älteren episode kari kann zum erzählen
wie man die schweiz und der schweiß
aussprechen muss sehr gute frage die
schweiz und der schweiz muss man sich
vorstellen ein set generell im deutschen
ist wie ein tee und ein ass stz schweiz
man kann quasi auch schweiz mit ts
schreiben und das andere ist schweiß ein
scharfes s schweiß alex thomas schreibt
weihnachtsmann oder christkind sehr gute
frage ich habe mich da ehrlich gesagt
auch zum ersten mal mit beschäftigt es
gibt angeblich oder nicht angeblich es
gibt in verschiedenen regionen
deutschlands
glaubt man entweder handeln
weihnachtsmann ohne an das christkind
und zwar hängt das auch etwas mit
katholischen regionen protestantischen
region zusammen man sagt generell glaubt
man in süddeutschland eher an das
christkind in norddeutschland erneut man
total spannend weil ich das frei auch
nicht wusste bei uns in der familie also
haben die früher immer gesagt dass wir
das christkind ganz immer geklingelt
das christkind da
ja man truhe schreibt hallo karin mein
name ist yaman und jetzt lerne ich
deutsch gratulation dazu meine frage ist
was bedeutet was ist die bedeutung von
rutsch für mich sieht es sehr komisch
aus wenn man sagt einen guten rutsch ins
neue jahr ist gerade mal für dich
nachgeschaut also rutschen erst mal
rutschen ist im englischen to / man kann
zum beispiel eine rutsche runter
rutschen im kindergarten also auf dem
spielplatz man kann auch wenn man auf
dem schlitten fährt im schnee kann auch
sagen man rutscht
wenn man auf der straße hin fällt weil
es gelangt ist zum beispiel dann rutscht
man auch deswegen ist das für uns gar
nicht so ungewöhnlich rutschen mit
neujahr es ist ja neujahr meistens
schnee oder glatt oder kalt da rutscht
man sowieso durch die gegend für uns hat
das also quasi eine ähnliche situation
wie es zur jahreszeit passt tatsächlich
ob ich das grab mal nachgeguckt uns gibt
verschiedene erklärungen du kannst mal
auf wikipedia eingeben guten rutsch und
dann findest du dann verschiedenste
erklärung denn es gibt alternative
erklärungen was woher kommt das da wird
zum beispiel mit den gebrüdern grimm
erzählt oder mit goethe musste der mal
durchlesen vielleicht findest du eine
erklärung an die du glaubst monitor
schreibt vielen dank alle teilnehmer in
dieser episode sie meinte sylvester
diese west episode
sie war extrem ungewöhnlich und spannend
jedoch habe ich eine bemerkung ich würde
sagen dass alle leute die ihr interviewt
habt besoffen sind insbesondere der
junge bei 145 habe ich recht habe ich
recht einen guten rutsch ins neue jahr
harmonie dass es gut ist darauf hinweist
dass war mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen
zuvor high oder hat 1126 schreibt carrey
luchse little vom punkt punkt rang endes
video ja was soll ich dazu sagen also
ich muss natürlich dazu sagen es ist er
um mitternacht werber dieses video um 12
uhr
wir haben aber schon seit fünf ruhe
langeweile und da haben wir natürlich
schon ein paar bier getrunken habe mich
aber zurückgehalten
dazu sagen johnny die hhs ist an real
can't believe this is liegen die looks
like complete anarchie genau das ist es
eine frage mich wie bei kali hast du
schon mal n hast du schon mal ein
arabisches land bereist und welches land
möchtest du gerne in zukunft besuchen
ich liebe eure videos
ja aber ich habe noch nicht so viele
länder bereist aber ich war schon in
tunesien tunesien ägypten und im oman
das waren sehr schön reisen ich mag die
länder sehr ich würde gerne auch noch
mehr reisen und werde das auch tun und
gerne fahren würde ich wo würdest du
gern informiert also ich würde gern nach
jordanien
kuala lumpur das ist ja kein arabisches
land also ich würde gerne ich würde gern
nach jordanien fahren auf jeden fall
also dass wir so 1 den nächsten länder
ägypten tunesien auch nochmal ich will
super gerne in den irak fahren leider
ist das gerade nicht so gut zu weisen
ja irak und syrien sind glaube ich super
schön wenn jetzt da nicht gerade krieg
wäre und weitere chinesische zeichen die
ich nicht verstehe schreibt eine frage
ich habe sehr oft sozusagen gehört was
heißt sozusagen eigentlich oder mit
welchen fällen sagt man sozusagen also
wenn du das erst mal definieren willst
sozusagen ist ein adverb und auf
englisch wird jetzt übersetzt mit es
etwa in dem männer of speaking oder rote
sale sie nun im deutschen sind unter
anderem quasi eigentlich gewissermaßen
irgendwie und das wort wird weniger
wegen seiner eigentlichen bedeutung
benutzt sondern ist mehr so eine art für
wort und manche leute sagen dass der oft
manche leute benutzen das fast nie es
ist so wie quasi es gibt leute die sehr
auf quasi sagen haben wir auch schon
richtet genauso gibt es leute die oft
sozusagen sagen mir ist das gar nicht
aufgefallen dass das glaube ich unter
die episode mit manuel und kari
antworten kommentiert das ist ja
sozusagen hoch interessant dass du uns
das quasi gesagt hat dass wir sozusagen
häufiger mal das wort sozusagen benutzen
ja mich hat mir gerade noch mal eine
bessere erklärung gesagt denn es hat ja
auch wirklich eine bedeutung in manchen
sätzen und zwar kann man das ganz gut
benutzen wenn man etwas etwas sagen
möchte oder einen begriff benutzen
möchte aber den nicht hundertprozentig
zutrifft oder man sich nicht sicher ist
dann kann man sozusagen da drüben
schreiben wenn man zum beispiel sagt der
eintritt war sozusagen kostenlos
dann heißt das man also der eintritt war
vielleicht mich eigentlich kostenlos
aber man ist zum beispiel eingeladen
worden
dann sagt man ja der eintritt war
sozusagen kostenlos also nur mal so als
beispiel oder das ist jetzt sozusagen
winterwetter in deutschland kann man
verschiedene definieren weil im winter
kann es in manchen gegenden sehr kalt
sein und sehr warmen aber auch in
anderen gingen
und wenn man nicht genau sicher ist wie
man das definieren möchte kann man
kleine sozusagen nach vorne
ja liebe leute jetzt fragt ihr euch
sicher wer hat denn eigentlich das
gewinnspiel von weihnachten gewonnen
wie ihr euch ändert haben wir ein
bildwörterbuch verlost und wir haben
eine kleine überraschung für euch denn
wenn das ganze nächste woche machen wir
haben tolle einsendungen bekommt alle
videos von euch wir uns wahnsinnig
gefreut und wir haben uns alle angeguckt
und weil wir noch ein paar sonderpreise
auslösen wollen wollen wir nochmal bis
nächste woche warten dann werden die
gewinner bekannt gegeben und dann
erfährt er
wer das buch oder vielleicht auch die
bücher gewonnen hat ja liebe leute das
war's auch schon mit der ersten kari
antwortet episode im neuen jahr
wir haben uns gefreut über eure fragen
nächste woche kommen noch mehr fragen
und dann werdet ihr erfahren wer das
buch gewonnen hat
danke fürs zuschauen danke für eure
unterstützung bei katrin sie hilft uns
wirklich sehr und wir würden uns freuen
wenn auch ihr vielleicht in zukunft uns
unterstützen möchte und dafür sorgen
möchte dass wir regelmäßig und noch mehr
ist german produzieren kann
danke für eure unterstützung da christus
schauen und bis zur nächsten woche